good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday that feels like
a Monday that also feels like a Thursday
because this is our first episode of the
week and our most recent episode is
since last Wednesday we have missed you
dearly hey Jax how you doing I'm doing
good thank you very much so excited to
be back on the podcast so much to share
from my time off so much content
consumed so many thoughts were created
yes I look forward to chatting with my
girl because you had a busy weekend I've
rarely seen you I know we haven't even
spoken um I think we're gonna have a
really juicy TV reading but we talked
yesterday a little and we did talk about
the crown today's episode we're going to
talk about the crown did you finish the
whole season
yeah
so did I I also finished Love is Blind
last week which I feel like it's so
funny how like
shows get so hot and so cold so fast
like Love is Blind feels so irrelevant
even though it was literally the episode
came out less than a week ago
um but I'll talk about the finale and
like the cuties gate which I'll explain
to you there's like a lot of drama going
on we could talk about that in the TV
recap but otherwise how was your time
off Jax what have you been up to since
Wednesday so I've been home chilling a
few different things I spent like one
whole day watching the crown I forget
which day it was I read a lot so excited
to share with everyone my book updates
because I finished two books and then I
started a new one last night and last
night I also watched the premiere of
Yellowstone which was so good I'll recap
that during the TV TV recap
you know what like I've been like very
against Yellowstone I don't know
anything about it I just like you're
watching and no like I know I'm wrong
um and I never really cared but now that
like the season premiered and everyone
was like talking about it on Instagram
like I do have fomo you would love it so
much everything I don't know everything
about it is 10 out of 10. jacket is so
busy like I'm so busy but you watch Love
is Blind so I just can't
feel bad because Love is Blind like they
give me four episodes at a time you
could take four episodes at a time of
Yellowstone no but now it's like
premiering on that and like a weekly
episodic basis it's just like a lot of
work for me but like you could literally
watch all the seasons in one week and it
still wouldn't be enough for you I am
Diana
um well yeah okay we'll talk about that
you know what I'll just find my time
until you come around and you say Jax I
should have listened this is Downton
this is reading well speaking of things
um I should have listened to about
yesterday was the first meeting of my
book club and I really you know it put
into perspective for me like how far
I've come when it comes to reading I saw
her like emotional nostalgic Tick Tock
you want to know why because I feel like
one of my lesser qualities is my like
stubbornness and how when I dig my heels
in on something
um
I just go for it even though like I'm
usually not right and with reading like
it was just always this thing like I
would never do it's like this mountain I
would never climb and now that I'm at
the top of the mountain I've read over
100 books my book club officially
started last night I really was able to
see
how far I've come which when it comes to
reading which isn't a big deal but the
fact that like I now enjoy something I
swore I would never enjoy like I I
conquered my own stubbornness that for
me is like the big deal it's not about
the reading it's about what the reading
represents yes but I also think that
reading a hundred books in under three
years for someone who didn't read before
is a huge deal I mean I had the same
feeling for myself I didn't read before
2019 and now I read so much and and I'm
I feel so accomplished I feel so
accomplished and also now that like I'm
a part of a book club like it's a
gorgeous way to spend a week night like
we had so much fun it was you know we
got to gossip a little we we talked
about the book a lot but like we also
like are just friends so we just like
talked about life
um we got ice cream my friend cooked
dinner it was so nice that's so nice I
want to hear about the book club Tings
and obviously I love love a book club we
have a podcast called the redheads book
club which you should check out I've
heard if you want to like join a book
club but you don't have friends to read
or people who would want to do such a
thing with you the redheads were the
book club like always there for you the
remote book club
the RBC the RH BC
um so the book that we read for book
club was called Woman on Fire by Lisa
Barr I gave it five stars which is
really maybe only the third book I've
given five stars to this year
um it was very you very not me I don't
really get into historical fiction and I
do kind of um
I do feel definitely a little weird
about historical fiction when it comes
to World War II in the Holocaust because
there are so many there's millions of
horrendous stories worth telling so I
don't know why we have to like make
stuff up but I was able to look past
that because it was an excellent book
and I got a lot of context the history
around it is real just this particular
story like these people didn't exist um
and I was able to learn a lot about like
thievery um you know destroy the
destroying of art during World War II
and just like another element of the
Nazis being Nazis
yeah I learned a lot about the
destruction of art during World War II
from my other non-fiction book that no
let me talk about the princess by uh by
I kept calling him Lionel the author I
think his name is Larry I don't know but
um I agree with like I hear what you're
saying about you don't need to make
stuff up about the Holocaust in World
War II like there's enough stories but
typically these historical fiction books
like it's an author who doesn't have a
personal connection or a story like that
they of one person that they want to
tell so anytime you're like
ad-libbing adding conversations it's so
it becomes fictionalized and two a lot
of these authors kind of amalgamate
different pieces of true stories and put
together one story that gives you so
many elements of things that did happen
so it doesn't bother me so much but that
reminds me of that show and I think we
talked about this a few years ago what
was that show called Hunters hunters and
they fictionalized a scene in one of the
death camps that was like really brutal
vulgar form of torture and that didn't
happen and it's like well there were
enough things that that did happen that
were true so that's weird to to add that
yeah and I know a lot of people feel
that way like a lot of my friends like
will not read fiction when it comes to
world wars you just as like a principal
and I get it
oh I didn't know that I mean I wouldn't
read like
what would they watch in glorious
bastards
Inglorious Bastards is different because
it's really fantasy like only if only we
could have gathered all the Nazis in one
room and burned that [ __ ] to the ground
it's like it's Fantastical in the sense
that like if only it could have gone
that way so were some of your friends
who don't read World War II fiction in
your book club no no I just know people
like won't do it that was the
conversation that a lot of people were
having over that Amazon Prime show
Hunters people just like wouldn't watch
it because why fictionalize uh an event
in history that has so many stories
worth telling
yep I do think like World War II
historical fiction books and and that
scene are different
because the scene said no the pictures
that they're painting in the books that
we're reading like are real things that
happened
Titanic like Jack and Rose Jack and Rose
weren't real passengers but yeah
everything else about the movie is true
and you get a picture of what happened
on the Titanic yeah no but the whole
story that they were telling during
Hunters was not true not just that one
scene oh really what what else
no like those characters didn't exist
the one two are hunting Nazis yeah like
it was a fictional TV show got it
so that's like a principal thing and it
definitely like it does it's not enough
for me for me not to read the book and
I'm so glad that I did read the book
yeah yeah and it also makes it like more
of unfortunately entertainment
storytelling you got to get through the
book oh by the way and then we chose our
book for next week and we were very
inspired by the redheads next month
sorry next month I'm like ambitious
liquor in the dark was uh Dana's
redhead's Choice from the summer so good
for your book club so good just to read
in general and it's pretty spooky stuff
so that's what I told everyone Jackie I
said Jackie recommends and the whole
book club respects you
wow
they said what did Jackie say what did
Jackie say here they respect you wow
that's so so sweet and I think that
flicker in the dark though while you're
reading it you're gonna be cursing
Jackie like I'm spooked this is scary by
the end you'll be like oh Jax did it
again
Jack strikes again even though it was a
Dana's choice
um tell me about what you're reading
wow well it's only fair because I spoke
about mine so so much so last week I was
reading The Accidental Empress by Alison
Pataki who is a historical fiction
writer I'm sure it's about real people
in history but you know
you should use it up a little bit so
accidental Empress is about CC Empress
Elizabeth of Austria who's the empress
during Austria's Golden Era and she
she's the subject of the show the
empress on Netflix and so I just wanted
to know more about the girl and I'm so
glad that I read the book it actually
has a second book which I wasn't going
to read at first but then last night I
started it because I was missing CeCe
after reading a book in between and the
first book was really great I feel like
I've got the picture of CeCe of her
first 20 years or so on the throne and
actually I'm so glad I read it when I
did because in so many ways she reminds
me of Princess Diana and reading that
book I feel like gave me more context
and a better understanding of like
Princess Diana's position when I watched
the season of the crown because I feel
like all the princess Anna stuff like
happened when we were too young to
remember it yeah too old to have read
about it in history so I like can't
I don't really know exactly what
happened I don't have an opinion on it
necessarily and so I really look to
things like the crown to understand that
period of time now of course as we know
Judy Dench lets us know like the crown
is fiction it really is mostly true like
let's get real I know and I found that
this season like this whole thing about
like Charles has a plot to overthrow the
queen like that is a stretch he didn't
have a plot he just like no I don't
think no I don't think that they really
has the itch I don't think they made a
team like he was plotting to overthrow
it's just like he really was so
impatient and was like definitely
crossing a lot of lines because he
literally was so bored yes but in the
media before the show came out they were
like there are a few storylines this
season that didn't happen including
Charles's plot to overthrow the queen
and it's like that's not what happened
in the crown he just has this Perpetual
itch because he's a bored old man and so
I feel like
maybe this isn't my shouldn't be my
takeaway but I just feel like the crown
is so close to the truth and and
everyone keeps telling me that it's not
but I just feel like it is no I have to
live that way I have to live right like
otherwise what the [ __ ] am I watching no
one sick hundred percent so even though
some things with a grain of salt they
definitely like more some people more
than other people and some people come
off well I felt like it gave me a better
sense of like Diana's final years within
the forms and the marriage while also
being very Diana
uh Philip you know no it was definitely
Pro Diana because a lot of the the stuff
that we've seen of Diana like Spencer
with Kristen Stewart there's been a
million movies she really was
um she was not well like she was
struggling a lot and I feel like they
didn't even mention that in the crown
yeah and so reading CeCe so she's
another one who's like a really Young
Bride she comes to power well Diana
never was Queen but comes to Royal life
very young and it doesn't have like a
full sense of self before she does and
then like everything is thrust upon her
she's incredibly popular with the people
like they love her at certain times like
she's the only one keeping the habsburgs
on the throne because they love her so
much and like that's the popularity that
Diana had there are a few differences
one being like Cece and Emperor friends
like we're so in love when they got
married and so like every time he wasn't
there for her like she was heartbroken
and she had no one and I just like never
got the sense that Diana and Charles
were so in love but then Daniel's gripe
in the show is that like Charles didn't
love her enough and it's like girl do
you really care about Charles no I agree
and I have no proof of this but like I
just wasn't like vibing with the idea
that Charles like left Diana and Dan I
was so in love with him and that was
really and that was saying in the show
that was Diana's biggest and only
problem really was that she didn't Get
Enough Love from Charles like that's not
I don't I don't think that that's it I
don't think that that's it either so of
course not I mean like he's like
she is Diana and like he's like fugly
like let's be real
yeah I mean it's not about looks but I
just feel like it was a it was a
marriage like most Royal marriages like
mostly a Business Partnership yeah that
will bear fruit and you just hope to
have like mutual respect for one another
and get along which they couldn't do but
they couldn't do that yeah so anyways
we'll talk about the crown when we talk
about it I'm so glad I read the book on
CC and then I read the last rows of
Shanghai which is a historical fiction
book about the um Shanghai during World
War II and and a lot of the Jews who
fled Germany and went to Shanghai had
I've never been in this time and place
and it was so interesting to learn what
went on it's from two perspectives one
of like a Jew from Germany who moves to
Shanghai and falls in love with a
Chinese woman and then we also get her
perspective of like falling in love with
a farm and
um it was cute it was
it was up and down yeah like it wasn't
great but I love I liked reading about
that time period And I definitely want
to learn more now so that's always good
by the way we are recording this episode
earlier than usual one because
um I've been up since 4 30. me and Ben
were on uh Fox Business today we did a
segment on Spritz launching in New York
which if you don't know we are now being
sold in stores in New York we just
launched in Alabama that's why my show
in Alabama was perfect timing
um but also I wanted to get the podcast
done before Taylor Swift pre-sale starts
which starts today at 10 A.M 10 a.m
eastern time which is like a huge
priority for me I know I'm up at 6 30.
um
I'm really shaken up like I was not
selected for verified pre-fan pre-sale
verified fan pre-sale
um and I really thought all hope was
lost and then Margo got the email and we
were planning on buying tickets together
anyway so like once again counselor
coming in clutch she's so connected to
that counts now she has to go with me I
don't know if she was planning on it but
now she has to
and I just want to wish everyone like
good luck today with the Capital One
pre-sale verified pre-sale like you know
you're gonna Bloom where you're planted
so whenever C2 ended up getting like
it's where you were meant to sit
good because it's the one you got and
you know literally stress does not end
after Taylor Swift pre-sale because our
toast holiday merch launches tomorrow at
10 A.M Claudia and I are wearing this
season's toasty crew necks we update
them every year and this season we're
going for like a plenier Vibe clean the
season we posted pictures on the toast
Instagram this weekend of all of the
holiday merch that's dropping we'll
continue to post pictures through till
tomorrow including like lay Flats of
everything that is actually launching
but to break it down for you we have
these two toasty crew necks I'm wearing
the white one mccartya is wearing the
pink one then we have two sets of
pajamas one set is black long sleeve and
long pants they're so delicious soft and
comfortable oh my God I was wearing them
literally 20 minutes ago TMT embroidered
on the left breast and the left thigh I
sound like a roast chicken and then we
also have a set of pajamas that are
creamy and pink and they are shorts and
short sleeves so some people like a warm
prajana pajamas some people like a hot
pajama to breathe yeah now this year we
have both for you we also have slippers
I'm actually wait wait also also
um a huge update on our pajamas from
last year is the buttons we wanted to
let you know we heard your complaints
last year the buttonholes were like a
little too big for the buttons like
sometimes you'd wake up with a nipple
out I had the same issue with my pair I
didn't mind but I understand that it's
not ideal for everyone we have updated
we've made sure that the buttons and the
holes are better so we apologize for
that we are constantly learning and
growing and this pajamas this year will
not have that problem my pajamas from
last year did not have that problem but
I have pajamas from other brands that
have that problem and so I understand
the frustration and we hear you we did
our best to ameliorate that this year so
we look forward to keeping to unfreeing
the nipple unfortunately right back in
jail no more freedom for your nipples
but we have slippers for your feet so
that I'm wearing the pink ones that say
p-g-o-w p jow precious gem of woman and
then we also have a black version that
say pgom precious gem of man perfect
stocking stuffer for this season along
with our blanket our blankets last year
were so popular I don't think you could
do a blanket as a stocking stuffer but
yeah you can yeah he's talking stuffer
is like it's like a metaphor it's not
like you know what I mean no no it's
pretty literal no I think it's a
metaphor like it's talking self her you
know
no it's like okay the mug is a stocking
stuffer yes the mug is a stocking
stuffer just make sure you have the
ornaments make sure you have a stocking
stuffers yes well the ornaments would go
on the tree right right right yeah our
TMT ornaments which always sell out are
back we have hundred percent and it's
worth noting that this will be our final
collection not just holiday our final
collection with the morning toast so a
lot of the merch has updated to toast
but we wanted one last collection that
says mornings so some of the products
say morning the blanket says don't talk
to me until I've listened to the morning
toast the blanket is so comfortable
Bryce has completely co-opted it which
I'm happy for him like he deserves
comfortable blankets real but man I like
it's new can I have a beige it's very
aesthetically pleasing
it's so high gee and it's really topping
out another stunning holiday collection
from us that launches Wednesday that's
tomorrow 10 a.m Eastern Time on our new
link which is
toastmerch.com you still can go to shop
morning toast like your browser probably
remembers it and you'll be redirected
but we officially have re-rented our
merch now to toastmerch.com
um not to be confused with hermes.com
and you'll be redirected because
obviously yeah but actually it's it's
toastmatch.com and shopmorningtoast.com
like just to actually not confuse people
and then Hermes and Jamal of course
right
um so if you're looking for inspo picks
what the sizing is I'm wearing large
what are you wearing
it's a great question because I always
get a medium but I always want a large
so let's see if I actually requested
what I wanted
I got large
and the pajamas
at Shop nope at toastmerch.com
toastmach.com I'm wearing a large but it
fits like all other toast merch I
usually wear medium but now but this
large I just I cover more thigh it's
like a Cozier 100 for me 100 very high
so laggy so that launches tomorrow 10
a.m eastern time so like we're not gonna
see you guys again until after the
launch
godspeed You Know godspeed godspeed
limited inventory I think that goes
without saying limited in the sense that
once it sells out it's not coming back
but we have ordered a lot of stuff so oh
you should be able to get what they want
but it's not unlimited the limit does
exist right and we're dropping it so
early because we want to ensure that
everybody gets everything before
Christmas like so the post office at
this time of year
every year we drop it earlier and
earlier and every year we're like biting
our nails that you know we hope the last
person gets their merch and so this year
we're like
even earlier more leeway more lead time
Morley way
um so hope you guys can get what you
want
and what I want this winter break is
sure then and how's that going for you
so good
so good I get what I want and this
winter break I want Jordan good because
it's who I can get
deceased
um so we have a fabulous show again lots
of TV recap lots of news to catch up on
so I say we dive in what do you say okay
without further Ado
where are you
I miss those stress brethren
do so do you broom no needs his auntie
yes he does Bruno laid in your bed
yesterday
missing his auntie hmm missing his
auntie missing his auntie dear did Harry
get in there too
sniffed around oh Auntie was here I miss
her Careless Whisper her beautiful
singing voice Brew was saying these
things not Harry no not yesterday at
least
speaking of rolled I did want to say I
had an amazing weekend out on tour I was
in Charlotte Durham and Birmingham the
last travel leg of the show which was
amazing like seriously everyone who came
it was really special and I got such
good gifts for rolled I also got these
leggings I'm wearing somebody brought me
Lululemon leggings like not the
expensive leggings no I know and they're
really amazing I'm wearing them right
now shouldn't you get like the lemon
hype
like I still think it is a manipulative
cult but I get the hype for sure not as
manipulative as lularoe
but the thing is with lularoe like I
understood the hype because those
leggings were absolutely gorgeous they
had pizzazz
Charisma lularoe greater than Lululemon
is that even a question I think some
people are questioning it
it couldn't be me I missed the lularoe
days take me back I know to like that
iconic documentary yeah and like our
iconically hot takes
Justice for those women honestly Justice
for lularoe
Justice for mlms
and checkers for those who wish to
participate in mlms at their own free
will and are having a good time because
freeway just pleased just please don't
message me on Facebook no totally unless
you're selling that rodent in fields
last serum I'll take that that's some
good [ __ ]
or you have or you have lularoe leggings
that are the spooky scary skeletons
they exist what'd you get I got a
somebody brought me a pair of pajamas
that they found at Kohl's
um to the meet and greet and they are
extremely similar to spooky scary not
exact but so far it's the closest I've
gotten to replicating my now deceased
pair of Target spooky scary skeleton
pajamas look really close they're truly
deceased those pairs Jackie who am I the
skeletons on your pants yes how did you
know oh I miss those pajamas you haven't
been wearing them as much
no they're literally ripped there's like
a hole in the crotch like they're done
you're done take them to the tailor
I know that's like psychotic to spend
like a hundred dollars altering a five
dollar pair of pajamas but like the the
place it has in my heart Priceless is
invaluable yeah no that's true send me
the bill
sure no that's how important to me they
are
spooky scary skeletons and shivers down
your spine
um so you didn't finish your sentence
without further Ado it didn't without
further uh do you hear Pastime stories
that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
honey what is honey well thank you
PayPal honey for sponsoring today's
episode they are manually searching for
coupon codes for you so the days of like
having to like Google like a coupon code
for this are over honey is a fabulous
browser extension that is free to
download when you use our link
um and they will do all the work for you
it is a free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies
the best one that it finds to your cart
I have been a personal fan of honey for
years I think I started using it in like
2018 I save money all the time when I'm
shopping online for makeup for clothing
for food for electronics whatever it is
pretty much every place I shop uses
honey and when I'm checking out this
little man pops down is like a dancing
gold coin he's wearing white sneakers I
think maybe they're Converse and he's
like hey girlie want to save some money
and I said yeah yeah I do I click his
little button four seconds they run
through a ton of codes the one that has
the most savings they will apply I have
saved countless countless money with 100
me and now did you know that I feel like
everyone uses honey online on their
computers but now they have a browser
extension for your phone so you can
download it on safaris when you're
shopping online on your phone you can
now save money there too which is
stunning
um if you don't already have honey you
are straight up missing out on their
holiday deals you're doing so much
online shopping this holiday season like
give yourself a break Download honey it
is free and it installs in seconds and
by getting it you're doing yourself
yourself a solid we would obviously
never recommend something we don't use
you can get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com toast that's join honey
j-o-i-n-h-o-n-e-y.com slash toast thank
you honey
um it's everything of the sore today's
episode is also brought to you by
bowling Branch after long days of
decorating hosting and celebrating
nothing feels better than a good night's
sleep in The Buttery soft sheets of bowl
and Branch their signature Hemm sheet
set from Bold and branch is made from
the finest 100 organic cotton that you
will ever feel and it has a really
luxurious experience that you'll enjoy
for years to come Jackie and I rave on
Instagram on podcast all the time about
bowling Branch being away from home
since Wednesday like I really cannot put
into words the joy I felt climbing back
into my bed knowing like I was being
comforted by the gorgeous hands of
bowling Branch we both have the
signature hem sheet collection they
offer a ton of different sizes different
colors we both have it in white we both
have King beds but whatever size you're
looking for whatever color you're
looking for bowling branch is there for
you also a great stocking stuffer
because giving someone the gift of like
a comfortable home is really invaluable
so their products are made different so
you can sleep better at night they're
made from 100 organic cotton the finest
on Earth they're free from toxins
pesticides harsh chemicals and they're
made by Artisans who earn the pay and
respect that they deserve give the gift
of a better night's sleep with bowl and
Branch right now our listeners get early
access to their Black Friday sale with
the promo code that's 25 off your first
set of sheets and free shipping when you
use the promo code toast at bowl and
branch.com that's bowling branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com that promo code
is toast and the offer ends November
27th so make sure you take advantage of
it and make sure that you're thinking of
people in your life that you love
obviously you should get for yourself
but also it's the season of joy and you
should be spreading that Joy with bowl
and branch and don't forget to use kotos
to offer ending November 27th thank you
mclared you're welcome
first story Gisele Bundchen's picks with
Joaquin Valente her son's Jiu Jitsu
instructor are showing Tom Brady what
he's missing it's been just a few weeks
since Tom and Gisele announced their
divorce but sources who know the couple
say the supermodel is sending a message
to her ex by posing uh
infligrante with Jiu Jitsu Hank Joaquin
Valente that must be constantly posing
in flagrante
that must be a saying because it doesn't
say flagrant and there's no noun after
that because that's an adjective but it
must be a pose flagrant and then an e at
the end like suppose I'm assuming a
Jujitsu pose
uh no I was gonna no like
they're not in a Jujitsu pose they're
just walking though no I saw like a
picture of them like
but I guess that was like back in the
Krav Maga like when they for I don't
know we don't know
well a lot of people
of posing in flagrante
maybe okay wait maybe it's because she's
Brazilian they're using a Brazilian word
Portuguese I'm just gonna
um Google it
flagrante I like have such a beautiful
accent when I speak in other languages
huh
okay very naked Kim and Kanye pose in
flagrante okay so it means nude
were they naked
not in these pictures
no okay what on Earth is going on in the
House of Commons I just missed that E
when I initially read the article or
else I would have had too many questions
but page six is told that Giselle has
known Joaquin blante who lives in Miami
for at least a year and a half she met
him after signing up her son for lessons
in the ancient art of Japanese
self-defense before taking lessons
herself while sources close to her
insisted she's not dating him who he's
believed
um a family Source said it certainly
looks like Giselle is showing off and
showing Tom what he's missing so the two
were rumored to be in Costa Rica walking
and people are being people are being
like so dumb like you know
that she was having an affair because
it's only weeks after and she's with
someone and like unless we not forget
how long it takes to get divorced and
I'm pretty sure Tom and Gisele have been
like separated for over a year so let's
just keep that in mind and not be stupid
I know it's really really difficult for
a lot of you but like let's not you
sorry like a lot of people not the
toaster yeah I feel like Tom and Gisele
have been on the out to a while I
wouldn't be surprised surprised if like
Tom has seen other people since I don't
think that the timing is like so crazy I
just think it's crazy like there's a
picture of them when they're I think
it's crazy that he's a nobody
yeah
what what you who were you expecting
Brad Pitt
I mean I would prefer it
um and I wasn't expecting anyone
specifically I just assumed the next
time she was spotted out it would be
with like someone on her left
you know that's short for level by the
way yeah but she dated she was with like
the Superstar quarterback
and yeah and maybe she didn't like not
being like number one yeah I feel like
when you go from being like A-list and
A-list couple like then typically
afterwards you you try something
different
right it's giving Casper Smart
but I do think it's really difficult to
engage in like a really meaningful
relationship with someone whose world is
like so different than yours you know
like she's literally the biggest
supermodel in the world and like he's
not yeah but I actually think their
words might not be so different right
now when she's just like in mom mode
because the article also said like he
could have been on vacation with the
family because the kids are home schools
and so their other teacher was there too
so like if she's just like constantly
with her kids in like this schooling
situation that's true one of her
instructors then like it's just like
your teachers it's you know Mr hall
right what was her name
I have no idea what you're talking about
Clueless
oh miss Geist
Queen
um yeah no I know what you're saying and
honestly it probably is nothing it
probably is like she's taking all the
homeschool teachers on vacation what a
life
um
so it's probably nothing even though
like the pictures like they were getting
a little bit flirty and fun but sitting
there together I think they're together
I'm just like this is not like the world
you know we were shipping Kim Kardashian
and Tom Brady like I was
envisioning like a lot of things for Tom
and Gisele and this was not one of them
although I do think because I was just
catching up on Kardashians I mean I
watched an episode where all the models
like the Victoria Secret girlies did
skims I do think like
Kim would maybe not date Tom Brady just
in the hopes of getting Giselle for
skins
but wouldn't she have been in that
campaign
could have that she's like so much more
than that like if they actually had like
their own campaign skims X Giselle like
that would be huge for scams like I
could actually see it bigger than some
of the other stuff that she's done no no
just like one of their iconic shoots but
you think she would turn down love for
that
what would she put first her business or
her heart
Kim I think she prefer business honestly
literally how are we talking about Kim
right now when she's never like there's
been no connection well people are just
like shipping her and Tom Brady because
it's literally like the most eligible
woman and the most eligible man right
now yeah okay well anyways Giselle seems
to have found love Matt before her she
also is doing Jiu Jitsu she posted like
some videos earlier this year of her you
want to know why I'm so funny hmm
because like if a major celeb like
started dating a nobody but the Celeb
was a man and then nobody was a woman
like I would be obsessed really like yes
I think like it's literally like one of
my romance novels like it's when the man
is like fancy and Rich and just plucks a
girl out of obscurity obsessed a girl
like JLo and Casper Smart like the way I
hated that relationship like I don't
[ __ ] with that like a woman that
powerful needs someone on her own level
like okay she deserves that now I
understand what you're saying you're
saying a lot of euphemisms but I know
you're like core issue it's like the
money
and that's what you see in your books
like in your books when it's like the
woman makes so much more money than yeah
it's money yeah I don't like that but
like if Gisele was dating a nobody
billionaire businessman then you never
heard just obsessed
you know it is all about the money and I
was thinking about that recently like my
my like the way I see gender is like so
unequal like I'm like okay I was singing
the other day about how like
if there was like and this never happens
but like sometimes like you know
female like not influencers but like
female fines let's say female
influencers or like reality stars they
like you know start a business and then
like their husbands like start managing
the business I'm like ew like literally
like get a job like stop but then like
let's say this man gets a platform and
he like has his wife like you know run
the business I'm like I'm obsessed yeah
you know
I think that because it's like seriously
like a man leeching on a woman like get
out of here it's very traditional that's
what it is you are very traditional but
I think that that's okay to like expect
different things from men and women
I agree because we are different yeah
and we we have different strengths and
different weaknesses
so when like a man is like playing to a
women's strength it's like what about go
chop down a tree
right get back to work
you know I just I think like the way I
see gender I've recently become really
aware of like my very um like stare not
know gender bias gender bias it's a
little stereotypical also just like a
double standard double standard that's
it I think that it's okay like
I'm a double standardized girl I don't
think that everything that you should
say to women should apply to men I don't
think everything they should say about
men should apply to women
I agree I agree
so anyways I mean I majored in gender
studies oh you're a gender studies
nightmare they would hate me in the
gender studies Department oh they oh but
they would look at they'd say oh this
project oh yeah yeah they think they'd
make me you know they'd make a man out
of me
maybe it's the holiday season that has
me feeling that way because you know I
turn it into like a male chauvinist when
it's the holidays you've like kind of
been saying these things all year but
yeah so you're saying it's not a
seasonal thing
no it's an annual thing
I don't think so
um but maybe this Jiu Jitsu instructor
is like the top of his field like owns a
bunch of jujitsu oh well
so he's a Jujitsu Mogul you didn't say
that he could be a jiu jitsu mogul
um okay well if that's the case I will
reevaluate yeah I just want happiness I
think he actually I read somewhere he
invented jiu jitsu
so
you know that means makes you think
money
anyways so enough in the comments if you
know what posing in flagrant means oh
please let us know flagrante
are you ready for our next story kind of
related but not really story
yeah of some new couple news
an m rata a reportedly dating and really
like each other move over Sebastian
Claudia bear mcclart and Kim Kardashian
Pete and Emily are reportedly dating
just for everyone he's 28 she's 31.
US Weekly Pete and Emily have been
talking for a couple months now they're
very they're in the very early stages
but both really like each other the
source explained that the two met
through mutual friends who set them up
The Insider said Pete makes Emily laugh
and he loves how intelligent she is
the couple initially sparked romance
rumors after they would spotted holding
hands on a date in Brooklyn on Saturday
night on Dumont
you know what
um I'm getting really sick of Pete
Davidson like every time he date someone
like it's so obvious like come on date
someone chubby like like just do
something different like it's the same
thing over and over like I don't know
I'm just very uninspired by his choices
it's like you know I'm I look for beauty
in a less standardized way I guess than
Pete and I'm just I'm I'm very
uninspired by his choices I really am
he's pretty like shallow
yeah except except that strangely enough
all of the beautiful women that he dates
also happen to be like incredibly
accomplished and I think and rata heard
you describing her as only a pretty face
like oh my God literally if I can come
for you she would and wait she also has
a podcast now so maybe she will come for
us because like if I just started a
podcast I also would attack like the
biggest female podcasters just so I can
like get my name thrown in the ring so
if she does it that's why
um no no I'm totally I'm kidding of
course Emily radakowski is like
extremely smart she's an author she's a
mom she's a model she's a businesswoman
um but she also like I'd be remiss to
and you know not acknowledge she's
arguably like one of the hottest women
on the planet like everyone agrees
literally copy and paste that sentence
Kim Kardashian copy and paste that
sentence Ari Kate Beckinsale right so I
think that Pete should go on the show
love is blind though because he keeps
going for the same person
and it's not working
no that's an amazing point also I think
it's worth mentioning like why I think
people are really drawn and intrigued by
Pete Davidson is because he is a little
ugly like a like he's not traditionally
handsome he has this look about him
where people either think he's like so
hot or not and that's what makes him
interesting and intriguing and I just
wish he would like apply that same
energy like why don't you date someone a
little ugly
yeah also he's tall
which if you're and funny you can get
away with a lot and funny
and funny and as stated he definitely
has this like je ne sequoise amazing
personality and like this chick magnet
yeah I was just like I was when I saw
this I'm like blase I'm like obviously a
hot people dating hot people what's new
honestly it feels like there's this
really small circle of single people
right now who are just like rotating
with one another and in our heads we're
like putting them together but it's
actually crazy that these two are going
out when they actually got together
fanfic
that's a perfect way of describing how
we all felt honestly yeah it's like it's
crazy that it hasn't even been like
adequately memed the two of them because
she really is like the most beautiful
woman in the world and Pete Davidson
exclusively dates the most beautiful
women in the world so it's like a parody
of itself and we're actually all kind of
over it because that's how fatigued and
I'm honestly really shocked that she
would even want to date him because she
like is so against being referenced by
her looks like I think she you know gets
offended if you refer to her as like the
most beautiful woman in the world so now
she's just like in a lineup of the other
beautiful women in the world and I feel
like it would be insulting to her
intelligence she's like a very new wave
feminist like that which must speak to
how much she really likes him
yeah and she and I have that in common
being like really feminists or really
liking Kim card Pete Davidson
I'm not even like I know I'm like
delusional Queen but like seriously if
Pete Davidson asked me out on a date I'd
be like no you feel like I'm married
I'm kidding I'm saying that's like my
actual my um like I think that's so
annoying I agree we'll say I agree but
yeah like if you had I'm always saying
to bed I'm like if you had to save me or
Theo like who would you save he's like
well I don't have to say it I'm like but
it's a game [ __ ] my pet peeve is like
when we're talking about and maybe it's
just like how we talk but we'll be like
if so and so asked to take me on a date
like will people be like but you're
married it's like it's a game no it's a
game it's called suspension of disbelief
like read a book it's a game chill out
it's a game relax
oh just a funny funny stuff
speaking of funny stuff
we've got more show coming to you
brought to you by Origins so Origins is
the pioneering nature infused skin care
brand that has elevated gift sets that
will surprise and Delight everyone on
your upcoming holiday shopping list
Origins creates transformative skin care
with naturally derived ingredients to
noticeably improve how skin looks and
feel they also have a long history of
commitment to the planet they reduce
waste and they care for our natural
resources
so Origins is just a brand that you can
trust their skin care products are
amazing I feel like everybody has at
least one product from origins in their
skincare routine but now with the
holidays coming up argents has you
covered because they have these amazing
gift sets that I've actually already
gifted to like a bunch of people in my
life and it's such a good gift to get to
someone because even if someone is like
not into skincare giving them the gift
of skincare is like something that they
can actively start in the New Year it's
like a really thoughtful gift and they
don't have to be like into Beauty for it
to be a good gift so all of their
holiday gift set cartons are plastic
free they're recyclable and they're
sourced responsibly for managed forests
for every tree harvested they also plant
new trees and to date the brand has
planted over 2 million trees around the
world so you can feel good about the
gifts you are giving this holiday season
from Origins
um the origins gift sets are available
at origins.com it is a perfect gift for
anyone in your life whether they're
really into Beauty and skin care or not
also it's kind of great for yourself and
talking about what we were talking about
earlier it actually is the perfect
stocking stuffer because it is a perfect
size for a stocking if I know my
stockings correctly for a literal
stocking right and I mean a stocking
stuffer in the literal sense here not a
metaphorical sense like not a metaphor
in a sense she right
it's uh origins.com check out those gift
sets you you won't be sorry you did
okay our next story Little Roney news
Ramona Singer confirms that she won't be
on Roni any longer Ramona Singer told
page six exclusively that after 13
seasons on the show she's not returning
to the real houses of New York she said
I do not want to do the show any longer
it's not for me at this time but sources
say that Bravo didn't offer the longest
serving member of the casting
opportunity to return for their revamped
liner lineup earlier this year the
network had announced that there would
be two new shows Legacy and the new one
we spoke about the cast members on the
new one and then on Thursday page six
reported that execs were hoping to keep
Luanne and Sonia from last season of
rahoni for the new show and add alums
Kelly bensonone Jill Zarin entered
medley plus a couple of TBD veterans
I want to say that of course like Ramona
says she doesn't want to do it and then
like Bravo says we were never going to
offer it I do feel like this is one of
those situations where actually two
things can be true at the same time like
I feel like Ramona probably knew she was
maybe she had a lot of backlash she had
a really bad last one or two seasons I
think she probably knew what was coming
and like made peace with it and actually
really decided that this because I saw
her on a podcast and she was talking
about like the new show and and she
didn't seem bitter she really actually
like seemed at peace yeah and we had
spoken about that I personally I
understand my Ramona if she felt like
she wasn't gonna be ass is making peace
with it maybe
maybe didn't want to be on it even if
she was asked but that doesn't seem like
the Ramona we know but I do think it's a
mistake on Bravo's part to not answer it
to her and and to not ensure that she's
on it like the show she's the only
full-time cast member for the last 13
years she is so much a part of like the
initial shows of the initial success and
and the DNA of the show the DNA of the
show
I think it's a mistake
I think so too especially if they're
looking to bring back like Jill like
really really OG people Sonia didn't
know these women Sonia is like season
five so to have only Luanne be like the
connector I think it's a mistake because
Luanne is really not polarizing like
she's very caught up in her own world
she's not like a drama queen Ramona is
and you need that and I do agree I think
it's a mistake yeah but I also feel like
Bravo doesn't want to like deal with
instances where people are like
constantly asking for so and so to be
fired and so like they have this and
they have that with like a lot of their
cast members yeah and and they slowly
like trim the fat Jackson Britney like
they're people who are polarizing yeah
and they just don't really want to deal
with that sort of stuff I think they
want to be very not controversial and so
they
get rid of these people who I don't
think they realize had so much to the
show and right
I think it's a mistake
well that's then like a really I think
similar conversation we would have about
Lisa Rinna
you know people call for her to be fired
yeah she is very polarizing
um and I would love for her to be fired
but I think it would be I'd be lying if
I said the show might not suffer like I
think it might yeah and now I think back
to other times where I was like this
person should be fired like I actually
especially when it comes to like how
they're acting on the show and acting
right like it's a Vanderpump Lisa
Vanderpump Vicky I was by by the end of
Vicki I was like we need no more Vicky
um right
and I think that when Bravo fires people
because like the fans have turned on
them I think it's a mistake you take out
like the one person who's causing
controversy within the show right and
then it's a lot of weak drama until they
find a new person to villainize and I
think what makes it really hard is that
the women refuse to film with that
person and like actually be friends with
them well that's different but that's
not what we saw with Lisa Rena that's
not what we've seen with um with Lisa
Vanderpump nobody wanted to film right
but like here's the thing it's a job get
to work get your [ __ ] ass up in work
and it's the network people whose job it
is to tell us what's good television you
know and to know what what's going to be
good not to just like listen to the fans
who just like are like I don't like this
person goodbye to that person
facts and I'm even talking to myself
because I feel like so many times have
yeah it's this person's time to go and
it's like I don't make TV shows what do
I know yeah no it's it's a really unique
balance of like hating someone all the
women hate them but like you have to
acknowledge that like they do bring
something to the platform yeah
they provide unity in everybody and the
fans like they provide a sense of like
Community camaraderie and feeling like
you know oh we're all together against
this villain true so as long as that
person's up for it
I think that's what's good television
well I think Ramona will definitely be
missed I think it truly is the end of an
era yeah
okay ready for our next story little
Charity news
charity World charity world is buzzing
because Jeff Bezos has vowed to give
away most of his fortune in his lifetime
right now his fortune is 120 something
Bill 124 billion and he's had Dolly
Parton 100 million dollars
to give away the vast majority of his
124 billion dollar Fortune during his
lifetime but admitted that ensuring that
the most worthy causes benefit is
proving as difficult as building his
Empire so he one gave Dolly Parton 100
million dollars to donate to Charities
of her choice as part of his annual
courage and civility award so that way
Dolly can keep doing her dolly Tings and
being the philanthropist queen that we
love Queen and then he also said that he
will give away most of his wealth in his
lifetime to causes
um I need to find the environment the
environment and then also causes that
would bring Unity amongst people's
okay so I obviously saw he was going to
be giving a huge chunk of his money to
like climate change in the environment I
mean we were just talking about this
with the CEO of Patagonia who left every
dollar to his name uh to the environment
as well I'm sure his children were
really happy about that
um and I asked the question then and I
didn't get a definitive answer and I'm
going to ask the question now like what
is money gonna do for the environment
like for real I feel like now we're at
the point where it's like so many people
the guy from Twitter everyone pledges
their billions to the environment and as
far as I know nothing's getting better
so I feel like you know we all like need
to stop like you know polluting and
littering and all that stuff and where
does money come into that like I'm
constantly confused how money helps
climate right like how the environment
accepts payment right to clean itself
yeah like I just don't understand how
money is the answer to climate change
like I know how money would be the
answer to Poverty because money is the
problem right so like or you know hunger
like childhood like I know how money
would solve other philanthropic causes
you know kids who need to go to school
scholarships like money is the answer to
all those things yeah baby to baby which
everyone's talking about because uh Kim
got that award amazing organization like
that money actually helps children
changing lives I don't understand like
and maybe I'm limited by my intelligence
here I don't understand how money helps
the environment yeah I want to say two
things one I think that you know the
person listening to this who's screaming
into the void would be saying like it's
about like investing in the cleaner
energy alternate uh forms of green
energy like
things in which pollute the degree in
less what
things in which to green things in which
to Green but two there are so many
figures that come out about how like
billionaires and wealthy people
contribute to more environmental have a
bigger climate footprint than like Earth
than a million lay people combined and
it's like no well [ __ ] stop telling the
lay people what to do and and maybe
that's why I can't hear everyone talking
while they get on their jet anyone who's
committed to climate change and and the
environment who's also stepping on their
private jet who's getting on Yachts
who's like doing all of these things
um your argument's null and void no
seriously take a sail but remember
when Leonardo DiCaprio once flew JetBlue
man and was like I've solved climate
change like no you didn't
um everyone like Harry and Megan are big
on climate change like nobody uses a
private plane more and of course I
understand like you can't be hopping on
commercial flights but like you can
really be cutting down how much you
travel and you can fly commercial if
you're flying like a 12 hour a flight
like you can sit in first class why
can't they play on commercial flights
why can't Jeff Bezos fight it's a
security risk for a lot of them I
understand why do you mean they have
security with them they no but like even
the way that like so many of them will
travel to a place together and take
separate planes I mean the Kardashians
like they'll all want a family vacation
like take six different planes yeah or
it's like Kylie wants to leave 30
minutes later
yeah
so but the Kardashians I don't feel like
are up my ass with climate change like
they're they don't bother me about it
there was I forget which Forum there's a
bunch of them but maybe it's like West
or Davos or something like that where
the subject was climate change and and
everybody took their own Jets and it's
like right oh there's people all those
Summits for climate change the private
airport is overwhelmed with inbound and
outbound flights no like they tell us
how to live and it's like we are
emitting less climate change less carbon
emissions in our whole life than you did
this afternoon no yeah and it's like we
actually like do stuff in our homes like
we switched out of straws like we do the
stuff stop preaching to us okay we don't
like what we contribute when I see you
switch out of straws no yeah our girl
well did not when I see people on Tick
Tock who talk about like they've
committed their lives to like zero waste
like they won't eat they went when they
go to the grocery store like they only
go to farmers markets and they bring
their own mason jars so they don't use
any plastic bags like you think about
all the waste like all the trash that
accumulates in one day and I'm like this
so admirable of you and it's such a
fruitless Endeavor because literally
like one celebrity leaves their house
for a night and everything you're done
you're doing is useless
it's over
so it's nice but I would love some
clarification this is a total genuine
question like how money fixes the
environment yeah also I'd love to know
what Dolly's gonna do with that 100
million
and I just want to say like if anybody
wants to give me an endowment
um obviously I will take a percentage of
myself just to like you know buy a house
and stuff but something I think is like
a really worthy cause and I could see
how money would help and it's an
environmental thing I'm always seeing
these videos on Tick Tock of like these
enormous boats that have been created to
fish trash out of the ocean and like
they'll they'll sail for like hours and
hours and then you'll see it's literally
like the craziest thing that's a worthy
[ __ ] cause yeah I love it it's so
satisfying to watch all the lot and like
these nets are literally built to be
able to not catch fish because it's like
you're casting a huge net in the ocean
you're gonna pick up trash trucks and
pick up a shark like so these these nets
are really special wow also out of just
curiosity the courage and civility award
has been around since 2021 and last
year's winner was banjos and Van Jones
and Jose Andres so let's know what they
did with their 100 oh yes I'd like a
follow-up I wonder if Jeff asked for
receipts
I'm sure there has to be some
accountability it's a hundred million
dollars I know I just I would like to
know as a layperson I just want to say
like I feel like we're always talking
about like celebrities like doing
charity yada yada and it's like how are
there still so many problems everyone's
apparently giving up billions yeah and
like with the giving pledge where
billionaires like pledge to give their
wealth to charity most of it because
they could never spend it in one or many
lifetimes
um there's a lot of Charity out there
but there's also a lot of corruption
yeah Corruption of course yeah as we saw
just in Selena Gomez's documentary
we the world whatever it was called we
charity we charity crazy stuff
are you ready for our fifth and final
story a little more Global News
it's like a couple of global girls
the human race has reached 8 billion
people
congrats humans we did it
congrats
I saw the craziest headline which was
that baby born on November 15th brings
the human race to 8 billion and it's
like you're not tracking
yeah human population in Israel because
do we know do we know who the baby is
and no yeah and it's like how many
people died in that minute too when we
went under and we went over like you
don't know and I'm sure there are people
who are not registered with the UN
right right also
um
I remember when we hit 7 billion I was
in high school and like everyone was
talking about it I was like oh my god
um so I guess it's been like 10 years
that's how long it takes to create a
billion people
net netting with the dead right so 8
billion humans are living on planet
Earth a huge milestone officially
projected for and being recognized today
by the U.N this matters because people
are living longer with generally better
access to healthcare food clean water
and sanitation than in past generations
and a smaller share of humans are living
in extreme poverty the Earth's
population has doubled since 1974 which
I find interesting
and countries that have populations of
over 1 billion right now are China and
India
then not us no we're in the in between
51 million and 250 million but I don't
know what I feel like that's it
um I feel like we're like 200 million
U.S population
damn maybe it's 332 mil maybe the
population count is off because I
definitely did not fill in my census
that's not good mclared then no that's
on me like it was a it was like a like I
I should have done it but like I'm like
why do you guys want all this
information you know I felt like someone
was on to me yeah it's a lot of personal
information like yeah no and like I pay
my taxes okay like leave me alone yeah
yeah but the sentence is like pretty
cool you know no it's like a good thing
and like you know if my ancestors in
hundreds of years want to track me down
there's going to be no information
because I didn't fill out my senses
aside from this podcast your Instagram
every piece of you that you leave all
your merch
all my merch so true they'll track down
their great auntie Claudia
be like wow my great auntie Claudia was
a star yeah they'll watch your specials
uh only when they turn 18. so I think
that the government knows about you
I think they know about me too I've been
trying to dodge them for years
good luck coming back anyways congrats
Earth we did it eight billion
congratulations class of 223 2023 which
gotta perfect that squeak we
no we did it okay that's kind of that
was kind of like how well did it like
cringy every time unless it's l no
offense are you calling me cringe not
you just what you said not you not just
the person I'm podcasting with but not
you
not you you're not cringe just the thing
in which you stated the screen
thanks
um let's dive into the TV recap the
crown is blind and Yellowstone TV recap
is brought to you by the solo stove
there's nothing quite like the feeling
of gathering around a warm fire on a
cool evening and a smokeless fire pit
from solo stove makes your outdoor
moments even more memorable because
instead of having to constantly Dodge
campfire fumes you can now sit back
relax and actually enjoy the fire with
solo stove and during solo stove's early
deals event you can get a great deal on
a solo Stove fire pit so if you want to
upgrade your backyard with a solo Stove
fire pit and create story worthy moments
without the Fireside fumes then check
out solostove whether you have a
backyard or if you live in an apartment
but you travel a lot and you think like
we have one um in the city and we
obviously don't have any space for a
fire pit because we live in an apartment
when we go on family vacations we're
always bringing the solo stupid solo
stove it's very portable it's very easy
to travel with it's super light
and it really is the best way to enjoy a
fire it is a stainless steel
construction and it is it is designated
to regulate airflow and burn more
efficiently there's so little smoke you
will wonder how there's so much fire it
is a perfect Catalyst for getting
outside spending time with family and
friends and you can build lasting
memories around a solo still fire pit
they are brilliantly engineered to be
easy to use and they're built to last
they're very easy to light with just a
few bits of starter and your fire will
be blazing in minutes at solo stove they
are so confident that you'll love it
they offer a lifetime warranty and a
30-day free return policy let the
gifting begin and Shop solo stove's
early deals event for a huge site-wide
savings that's ten dollars off with
promo code toast plus a lifetime
warranty and free 30-day returns an
extra 10 off holiday deal so they've
already have great deals at solost.com
then use code toast for an extra ten
dollars off again that's promo code
toast solostove.com
okay let's do it I'm so excited to talk
about the crown
for me I definitely felt it was a slow
season I thought it was a little
lackluster
um it's when episode 10 ended I'm like
okay on to the next episode it was not
final like I don't I get it it was like
two women two boats two different
stories but like it was just not
it didn't leave us on a cliffhanger but
it also didn't wrap anything up it was
just kind of abrupt yeah I feel like
this season and next season like could
have been all one season the way that
it's gonna be filmed it's like next
season episode one is gonna start like
five minutes after the end of episode
two like she's going to the boat in San
Tropez I actually enjoyed this season so
much I don't know if it was because one
like the crown is just a good show and
we don't have a lot of good shows and so
like compared to a lot of the other
stuff that I watch like this is good
even when it's not good two I didn't
love last season I felt like last season
was disappointing and so I thought this
was better than last season and
therefore really good I was actually
like even though you know I love all
things Queenie I was like not looking
actually I was looking forward to
watching the crown but like when I was
starting it I hate getting into a show
again and I just like didn't feel like I
was going to but I I thought it was
really really good initially and that
was surprising to me I also won Mr Queen
and I'm so glad to have a reason to talk
about her to to reminisce but this
period that we're in the 90s where it
was like a bad decade for the queen it
was the Queen's flop era it was her
flower it was her honest horribilis era
yes it was really painful to watch
um like knowing
knowing that obviously things got better
but like it was really bad for a long
time obviously I wasn't alive so I don't
recall it and I'm not even British I
don't even realize like you know what
the culture was like at the time right
and I have just watched the queen with
Helen Mirren so I know that like the
post Diana time was a really hard time
for the royal family because they didn't
handle it in the way that a lot of
people thought that they should have a
lot of people are very sympathetic
towards Diana feel like the royal family
and inadvertently killed her I didn't
realize that she had a number of bad
ears leading up to the Diana stuff so
like that makes that even crazier and
honest I'm shocked that there even still
is a monarchy after all of that and so
knowing
how close they were to perhaps the end
it's just yeah like crazy to look back
on and and now at this point like that's
30 years ago that's a long time ago
no and it's literally like when Charles
was being
satin business class while everyone else
was in first class like that was
shocking yeah but they do now I mean I
don't know if the king or the queen
flies commercial ever but everyone else
does sometimes In First Class yeah like
even when Harry was a prince like he
would be spotted on a plane yes that's
true actually so like uh no offense if
like royal family members can fly
commercial and figure it out so can
wealthy billionaires
facts
just saying so um
I enjoyed it very very much I know a lot
of people were Shook Up by the recasting
again well that's what I wanted to talk
about because I have to say I thought
Dominic West actually was excellent and
I was so against him being in it I just
like hate Dominic West and every time I
see something his he's in like he wins
me over with his his talent he's a good
actor
he's a good actor a lot of people are
saying like he's too handsome to have
played Charles but I think a lot of
people forget like when Charles was
young he wasn't ugly
yeah I don't think our issue with
Charles is his looks I like everything
else he was fine playing Charles I don't
find Dominic West like so handsome or
not handsome he's just like a man and so
is Charles Smith I think that on that
count it's totally fine and I was ready
to see like grown Charles because I was
thinking back to the characters from
last season Diana and Charles and they
were so much younger but the guy who
played Charles last season was excellent
I know but he was really such a kid and
so I refuse to be blamed any longer for
this quartet Miss Alliance
is that Tic Tac
it's Charles I know but is it famous
from tick tock not the woman you married
I refuse to be blamed any longer for
this grotesque Miss Alliance I wash my
hands of it yeah it's tick tock I
thought that Elizabeth de Becky has this
season's Princess Diana was a slave
excellent she's so good people did not
like the queen as the queen they don't
like I mean not apparently she's Dolores
Umbridge from Harry Potter and they
can't Square it away she didn't bother
me so much I think
some of the issue was like I could see
her being Queen Elizabeth but she wasn't
harking back to Olivia Coleman the way
that Olivia Coleman I felt like was
harking to Claire Foy like those two
they connected
was very congruous I felt like this was
more of a leap and I also feel like the
queen is in her flop era she's kind of
not as lovable this season and that also
overshadowed
how you felt about her
you know that's that's definitely true
like you were watching it through the
lens of like her just like honestly
flopping and like doing nothing about it
um and I know that's like her job to do
nothing but it was really frustrating to
watch and you really have to think like
what could they have done better to
avoid this flop Erin I think it started
with every single one of her kids
getting divorced and even before Charles
and Diana it was like Andrew and
Princess Anne and I just uh not to like
shame I do feel like
she took her job so seriously that she
definitely neglected some of her
motherly duties yeah and I think um she
was so blinded by her job and so
obsessed with making good matches for
her kids like she didn't even care if
they weren't even the slightest bit
happy because back in her day it didn't
even matter you had to stay married the
whole time but like divorce becoming
like really popular and like then
applying that Memorial family yet
becoming an option like definitely threw
her through a loop so like the way that
she kind of forced her kids into
marriages that they didn't want to be in
but then they eventually ended up having
it out really did make her look bad okay
I totally agree and I feel like
especially with Charles and Camilla it's
like if they just marry from the outset
this would be a completely different
story but then I was thinking about it
and I think that the queen after all of
the 90s kerfuffle did have an about face
and I feel like actually Harry and Megan
is a great example of her completely
course correcting from Princess Margaret
so Princess Margaret was the spare she
wanted to marry a divorcee who was not
in any way shape or form Royal and an
unsuitable match and she did not let
Margaret choose with her heart yeah
that's a good point is
the spare he marries a divorcee he
married exactly who he wanted to be
married for love and the queen did not
stand in his way whatsoever
but look what happened not to say that
like something bad would have happened
if Margaret could have married Townsend
but like
Harry married someone who doesn't have
that regard for the royal family as this
institution that's like infallible and
what's worse for the firm Princess
Margaret getting a divorce and being
unhappy or Harry and Megan being happy
and leaving the royal family and taking
a big hot steaming dump on it
I don't know what's worse but also by
the way I think that about face can also
be seen in William and Kate because Kate
is everything but she is a commoner like
she has no Royal Blood she's doesn't
have a title her parents don't have
titles
um
and I actually think it worked in their
favor for that because people love Kate
but also a lot of people wanted to be
Kate and like Kate gave every girl uh
who lives in London like uh you could be
Queen One Day [ __ ] look at me I'm never
I'm a nobody even though of course she's
very wealthy she had the connection she
went to Saint Andrews that's how she met
him like you have to be someone to be in
the same room as Prince William but she
really she was no
she was a nobody but I also feel like
yes William didn't marry a royal person
or someone of his aristocracy but like
those things don't really exist anymore
like it's not like there are other major
Royal houses of Europe the way that
there was a hundred years before but
people still have titles
yes but it's and a lot of the women that
like William was like out and about with
were these like socialite aristocratic
girlies like yeah
yes but like those titles one are
dwindling people are losing their houses
and they don't really mean anything like
they you they don't mean what they used
to and so to me that seems like less of
a leap it's not like if Queen Victoria
if the heir no it's way less of a leap
but it's still especially he's the
future Sovereign like he's not the spare
yeah I feel like with every generation
the rules lessen a little bit and I I
felt like the queen learned her lesson
with Margaret and then she applied it to
her kids in their second marriages and
then applied it with her grandkids to
her grandparents that's true that's
really true
um
I just felt like it was a big waste of
time of course oh my God I know it was
not a waste of time we had so many
iconic things that happened and like
this was the era 90s it's like really
like pop culture and when there's like
tabloids and Paparazzi and the internet
is coming about and like the interviews
like the the Andrew Morton book The
Martin beshear interview the Tampax
conversation like by the way stuff that
I've heard of but I didn't know about
really at all like I really didn't know
this tampon thing I know the tampon
thing I knew there was like a tampon
thing but I didn't know anything beyond
that let me tell you how how not cool
that is like
that's such an invasion of privacy like
it's so horibus
I don't think it's I but I also felt
like these iconic moments they also kind
of Breeze past like Revenge dress
yeah
no and it's like what I don't understand
the way I perceive Princess Diana and
maybe this is what there is to
understand it's like she was the creme
de La Creme doesn't get more A-list
could go to anything be friends with
anyone go anywhere on any trip and like
and she had nobody and she sat alone at
Kensington Palace like 24 7 watching
reality TV and college and she hated
Kensington Palace she hated being bugged
um but in the divorce settlement she
required that she keep her place there
yeah and like Kensington Palace is like
it wasn't just their house like they
lived among princesses the aunties and
yet she spent all her time with her when
she could literally go anywhere in the
world and anyone would have been so
happy to have her
no and it was really sad because I think
a lot of the
the things that she did like she was
clearly manipulated like the book the
interview she was not making the best
decisions because she had nobody to
count on like no friends no family
nothing yeah especially the Martin
Bashir interview which we recently had
spoken about William and Harry like made
a statement once it
surface that the BBC had used dishonest
methods to get Diana to sit for That
interview and like that's just so crazy
now seeing it like and what a that was
the nail in the coffin for Diana and
like if she hadn't been misled into
giving that interview like things might
have been ended differently
right so in a way where so many of the
people who say like the royal family is
responsible for Diana's death I think
one could argue the media is more
responsible for her death more
specifically the BBC right that's just
but who would question
like the BBC is like the governments
Broadcasting Service that's like PBS
coming to you with fake receipts and she
already has these suspicions and I'm
sure to some degree she was spied on I
think that they all are spied on like
the firm wants to know what everyone's
up to but to have her like she has so
few people that are she's actually close
to and then to have her question and
turn on those people and isolate her in
that way is just so horrible
agreed
um I just felt like I was waiting for
the other shoe to drop and I'm like
ready for the next season they really
need to have it out now I'm ready for
the next season just because now I'm in
it my favorite episode which I talked
about on my Instagram was the season the
episode six Russia Russia oh my gosh the
way I was living you know we talked
about it on the show because I watched a
documentary which if you if you liked
episode six at all you should watch it's
called the last Czar and it's about Tsar
Nicholas's final years with his wife and
his daughters and then Alexian and how
the conditions became such that there
was like this Revolution and such a
brutal ending to the Romanov family and
so I'm obsessed with like the ending of
the romanovs but what's so crazy is
Prince Philip's contribution to
identifying their Remains the show made
it seem like it all hinged on Prince
Philip and he was the one who connected
them like there were a lot of people who
gave DNA because there are a lot of
descendants of Queen Victoria and such
um
but I just found that episode so
interesting and then going back to Queen
Mary and King Edward and like the
initial match which is King Edward was
supposed to be with
Sarina over there but she like loved SAR
Nicholas and she went over to Russia
with him and
it's just and then the that woman Penny
who's like Prince Philip's girly and I
actually really like her and I like and
he deserves a friend he deserves a
gorgeous young friend the episode that I
liked the best was getting to know
Muhammad and Dodie like I the way I
would literally take a bullet for
Muhammad he's so I don't know what if
that's what he was like in real life the
guy who's playing him is making him out
to be so [ __ ] funny and he's
definitely like an anti-semite like he's
definitely racist but he's got Charisma
like he even like he he was saying
something anti-semitic and I'm sorry
like I was cackling it was so funny he's
like a gym
so funny the way that it was funny has
spent his billions is exactly how I
would spend mine trying to get close to
the queen trying to make the queen happy
trying accepting he's accepting scraps
like literally they sent the press
secretary to go collect all the things
and everyone is so disappointed he's
like what are you talking about we made
that Queen very happy
obsessed I I agree I loved that episode
I love his like stanhood for the queen
no but my God his son is a [ __ ] loser
big time loser oh my God his son is like
so cringe I can't cringe I'm curious how
eventually knowing what happens between
Dodie and Diana and the royal family
like
how Muhammad is going to swear like his
love for the royal family with like what
happened he's gonna grapple that he's
gonna have to really struggle and I
don't know what happened in real life so
I hope that the ground stays true to
that
um and then really quickly uh Love is
Blind let me tell you how the crazy oh
so that's it on the crown yeah
anything else you want to say I don't
know it's just so good like so in they
work so hard on the whole show and we
just like gave it 10 minutes you know I
feel bad I didn't think it was that
great
um I'm sorry was there anything else you
wanted to say I don't know I have to
think about it who else was there
like young William and Harry loving
getting to know the boys yeah and I feel
like we're getting to know William I
don't know him like that right no it's
crazy though that we've just like fully
caught up and now we're and now we're
here and now we said it and like William
is like offensive young boy and he seems
very
like level-headed and like he'll be a
good King and I'd love his like tea with
the Queenie scene no he's very tight
with Gran he's telling them Bond over
television yeah having her set like him
set it up like the Royals they're just
like us you need your kids to work the
TV 100
I guess I'll move on
um so love is blind whatever like the
weddings happen but this is what
everyone's talking about let me tell you
they did a reunion and this couple who
didn't get married Colin's and ebb
um she like read him to filth at the
altar and he was like not a good
boyfriend and they definitely shouldn't
have gotten married he was like really
immature
um and he just kept saying like you know
you're not like my usual type physically
so like I'm struggling with that and
they didn't have to say it as many times
as he did like he was a little bit of a
dick
um and then on the reunion she makes
these crazy accusations that he like
destroyed her self-confidence she he
would constantly make comments about
what she was eating telling her to stop
eating like really crazy stuff and
she was like you should just be really
really grateful that like that footage
didn't make it to air like the scene
with me eating the cuties the little
clementines we know those she's like
that scene like you are you're so lucky
and he's sobbing he's like I don't know
what you're talking about like I love
you and like I've literally you're crazy
lying right now and she's like oh my God
you're gaslighting me and people really
didn't know where to land and then
Netflix came in clutch with the footage
and let me tell you how much of a
nothing Burger it was like she's eating
fruit and they have this big dinner plan
tonight I think it's maybe like four or
five o'clock
and he's like oh my God we're gonna eat
so much tonight and she's like I know I
like haven't eaten all day like all I
had was a banana which is why I'm like
shoving my face right now with like
grapes and and fruit
um
and he's like what do you mean like you
only ate a banana today like he was just
asking questions about what she ate like
she had served up information and he was
just asking a question like a good
boyfriend should
um and it's clear that she like has food
issues and like she's on TV and trying
to fit into a wedding dress and like
it's you know it could be toxic it
really had nothing to do with him and so
like she is getting dragged to filth for
being like caught in pretty much a lie
um no a lot of people are coming to her
defense being like you know it it could
be her truth you know people love to be
like that her truth when someone's
caught lying
um she like released an apology
me and Margo are in the queue for Taylor
Swift tickets and there are over 2 000
people in front of us like there's no
hope and this is just for one show not
for even the whole concert okay
um she released a like an Instagram
statement
that was really uh she's not backing
down okay
she said
oh did she delete it
oh my God I think she did
oh
it's gone
she was like an apology to the internet
I'm sorry you didn't see what I went
through I'm sorry you don't know
anything about me it was like hella
aggressive
um
and so people are like divided like
having a conversation about like the
cuties thing but like a bunch of people
watch it and then like all looked at
each other and we're like was that like
nothing people were like what was so
crazy like the allegations she was
hurling during the reunion were like so
crazy and so we were expecting like
and if it was that big they would have
put it in
yeah I I'm glad that they aired the
footage I'm glad that he stood up for
himself because I think a lot of times
people can be silenced by being told
that like they did something so
egregious like that and and I think the
way that you're describing it she has
food issues and I think that not to say
this is her truth but some people like
hear something you could say words and
it goes into their brain and they
interpret it as something completely
different like they receive it
differently right so like for her he's
asking what she ate that day and maybe
it's because like he sees that she has
food issues and is concerned that that's
all she ate and like she's also someone
who just had a bananas eat stuffing her
face with grapes and clementines like is
not healthy not totally healthy and so
there's obviously a different Dynamic at
play and so I'm sure like she heard him
asking like oh so what did you eat today
and and she heard it with like a tone of
like what did you eat today yeah so it
was just like a really but I also think
it's important like so yes that's her
truth and that's how she experienced it
but I also think it's important to call
that [ __ ] out and be like okay sure but
that's not facts that's not what
happened you can't slander someone's
good name with with what's going on in
your head when that when you didn't
misbehave no I agree there has to be
some like sort of accountability because
the way like these days you'll call
someone something and that label sticks
with you forever
um it's so unfair today not even you
called someone something they felt a
certain way based on things based on how
you acted and what you said when you
didn't misbehave towards them it's just
like perhaps their insecurity or or
their personal issues that they're
projecting onto you and they and they
feel like you made them feel a certain
way because that's just how they feel
about themselves but then like you're
that you're the bad person you're the
bully and it's like if you want to you
know not operate in reality go ahead
right don't bring other people down with
you yeah and and slander it was an
otherwise good name he was like sobbing
on the couch it was actually so sad I'm
like who do I believe here because at
first I totally believed her because he
was like this like dumb immature like
whatever frat boy no and a lot of she
really has accusations like you're
inclined to believe them because of
course people shouldn't lie right
so you believe it so I was just shocked
because then they get the footage I'm
looking around I'm like am I missing
something this is not crazy good for
Netflix for releasing the footage
because otherwise would have been like
he said she said this person's name
would really be drugged in the mud and
especially it doesn't have a great track
record of saying you're not my type
right the shoe might have fit because he
didn't look amazing and he didn't do
everything right he wasn't a great
fiance and he's too immature and he was
a little too young like
he wasn't coming off perfectly and then
there was this cutie saying he was
already like people were inclined to
believe he he did what she said he did
because he was kind of like a prick yeah
it was sad
um tell me about Yellowstone Yellowstone
two hour Premiere I think mine was like
two hours 15 minutes because it
definitely went over the two hours but
it was so it was two episodes that they
dropped which thank you Queen yeah Tyler
Sheridan uh
I guess I'll be spoiling some of it um
our boys the governor and he's taking no
prisoners I literally chuckled out loud
with the scene with the driver when he
was like telling his driver not to
repeat anything that was said and then
the driver was like I would do
everything the same if I were you and he
was like I want this driver every time
um and I'm I'm a little worried you know
John is being a little bullheaded and
not going to do what's best for the
ranch I feel like I might watch
Yellowstone okay take off your things
um and not that I trust Jamie whatsoever
but maybe he knows what he's talking
about in terms of the legality of what
John is trying to do I also even I hate
Jamie and I wish they had a better or
maybe my TV just cut it off of like
recap of last season because like I
needed to get into like my hatred of
Jamie mind again because when Beth is
like so mean to him and won't give him a
whiskey and John is like telling her to
give him a whiskey so it's like oh well
John says it it's fine I just like want
her to be not nicer to him but I just
feel like the more the meaner she is to
him like the more she's going to push
him away and he's going to do something
crazy and diabolical as opposed to like
if he felt like he had a family maybe he
would act right but you know for years
he didn't they did treat him well and he
didn't act right and I need to remember
what happened last season with his dad I
think his dad hired the hit on the whole
family and then he did some other stuff
but I can't fully remembered
anyways Beth is our Queen Beth and rip
forevermore I wish they did a better job
of letting us know when something was a
flashback because the scene of the
telephone pole going up and the guy and
the acid I took me a while to remember
what was what but then I remembered that
character the guy who gave young rip the
truck and I was like oh this is a young
rip situation I don't give a rip
I'm still nope it's not safe it's not
safe no that's fine I just I do want to
alert you to the fact that we probably
have three minutes left on our memory
cards today's episode is so long so I
don't want you to uh okay I'm gonna take
my headphones back off okay all I'm
gonna say is that I typically don't want
like watching Ellis Yellowstone week to
week so I'm not going to recap it every
week unless like there's an outpouring
of support in which case I will watch it
we tweak I like to batch watch them but
I did watch uh the premiere because I
wanted to
get on the Yellowstone vibe that
everyone was on I didn't want to see a
spoiler accidentally though this wasn't
a really spoiler-ish episode so there's
nothing I would have seen on social
media but you know you get scared people
like are posting a tribute to Beth and
rip and I'm like oh my god did Rip die
no he didn't anyways things are good
when things are good for the duns things
are good for us and right now the
duttons are in a strong place which just
makes me nervous because you know what
goes up must come down and that market
equities lady is not happy oh and then
we have east coast Beth coming which is
I'm glad that we have you know someone
to counter Beth I think that will be a
nice antidote but to be like fake Beth
Beth with brown hair I'm not here for it
she walks like that she talks like Beth
she has her hair messy like Beth and
it's like get your own thing going on
you know those are my thoughts now I'm
good
all right thank you so much Jackie for
that gorgeous Yellowstone recapped I
enjoyed that immensely yeah because you
didn't have to listen to it I love you
sure
I love you and that is our show just in
the nick of time before our memory cards
run out before I tell you so much resale
no I'm I'm Gonna Be On Cue for like an
hour for sure time
[Music]
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the Monday Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes did your public video I already
have guest box oh the places where you
listen to podcast find us the toasty by
five star review about how we kiddingly
talented we are
have an amazing day right and we'll see
you tomorrow first day and merch drop 10
a.m set your alarms set your alarm.com
toastmarch.com 10 a.m holiday pie and
stocking stuffers gifts for your loved
ones love you bye